i got my copy of people magazine in the
mail because i'm a subscriber
and in it is an incredible spread
of many and several pages of all these
different
um veterans that are doing extraordinary
things please
check this out okay and another way that
people are honoring vets today
usa today reports that restaurants like
applebee's
wendy's starbucks are offering free food
coffee and more and all you need to do
is show your military iv
id card or va card yeah
i love when we have information like
that because you can just do it today
um and all craft week long we've been
going uh for some pinterest inspiration
pinterest pop ladies and gentlemen
i know i'm really excited sorry i
thought there was a graphic coming
that's why i paused
um i'm really excited to announce a
collaboration i'm doing with domino
magazine
one of my very favorite magazines
obsessed
i even got to be on the cover of the
very first issue of domino kids
with my girls and it's their first kids
issue ever
and i recently just launched my own
pinterest page
but i'm proud to announce on it there's
a collaboration
on the board and it's domino kids ex
drew barrymore
here are some pics that's actually my
pool house um
and i just really love kids worlds and
kids rooms we have flower kids
flower homes these are some things
you'll find on the board there's also
some really imaginative inspiration for
bedrooms
that's me actually holding jonah's
flower pillows
and the beautiful blanket he knit for me
we're actually going to see him in the
next news segment
so it all threads if you know what i
mean
okay so uh check out the pinterest page
at drewberrymore it's
full of stuff so uh all right it is time
to
talk bachelorette as an ongoing social
experiment
i'm watching bachelorette for the first
time ever it's batch watch
that's right now i think we do have a
graphic for that perfect here we go
um and uh boy did i pick good season
joining me today is entertainment
tonight correspondent and the host of
roses and rose
lauren zema hi lauren
hi thank you so much for having me you
are such a joy and you did pick a season
to begin drew you picked a season where
we're getting about
four seasons in one i mean this really
is
an unorthodox rollercoaster okay so last
thursday clara and dale officially got
engaged after all the scuttlebutt
she is not playing by the rules and
she's like barreling down on everything
let's take a look at this clip what's
next for you guys
moving in together wedding what's up i
think like you know
obviously babies uh
really like we we've talked yeah you
just you just skipped right over that
yeah you just can't fit in with it are
we having babies first we're gonna get
married first yeah we're gonna get
married first
whatever happens
drew that was the babies heard round
bachelor nation wasn't it you mentioned
that clarendale just got engaged and i
think this is indicative of the
speeding train that we are all on
whether we bought a ticket or not
i know and then entertain this is her
third
bachelor endeavor she was on the
bachelor and bachelor in paradise and i
think she's just
gorgeous and stunning and with her came
four new guys i mean
i feel like the guys on the show are
like we're all fascinated but the guys
on the show must be like
what is happening and lauren you just
celebrated your two-year anniversary
with chris harrison
who's you know master of ceremonies
is there like any fun like
tea to spill or things to watch out for
what i mean you must have all the
insides scooped how fun
you know i love to watch the show as a
fan so i will say
i try to avoid the spoilers because i
recap it on my show roses and rose so
i want to make sure that i am living in
the moment and doing things like hearing
claire say
babies for the first time with everyone
else because
what a moment it was drew i think that
tasha is going to be
the yang to claire's yang yeah i think
claire was a drag race and taisha's a
road trip
and in both situations there are sites
to see what did you think i need your
opinion drew on that moment with
clarendon
i'm just glad i picked such a wild
season because it does keep it really
fun and there is more to discuss with
everyone and that was the point of all
of this and i'm just like you lauren
i like to keep my reactions really fresh
so a lot of like everything's very
planned here
we're very detail-oriented but there's a
lot of spontaneity and you can't fake
that
so i'm with you keep it fresh lauren
thank you so
much for coming on and maybe we can do
this again
oh drew i would love it because there's
going to be more as i said we we got
last season last week we got what a
fantasy suite a season finale in a
season premiere all in one
and then we got another season premiere
and after the final rose last night
so drew i just sip your coffee and let's
talk about it more okay
i need the caffeine roses and rose also
do not miss her show
and we'll do more of this if we can